By the way, everyone has the license to disobey
political correctness.
I feel that everything is about good taste
and self-restraint.
My favorite comedian of all time is Richard
Pryor so I'm not a prude, but I think some
things maybe you can say more eloquently.
Some things you can say in a way that if you're
intelligent you'll pick up on it, and if you
won't, you don't.
Subtleties, nuance—that's what gets lost
in the whole big battle of political correctness.
I don't believe in any political correctness.
I don't think even if I'm talking about like,
you say to me, “Who's your favorite comedian,”
or, “Who do you think is up and coming,”
and I name two male comedians, that does not
mean that I think female comedians aren't
funny or I don't have a favorite female, it
just means in that moment I thought of those
two people.
Yet there are people who will have a strong
opinion on that moment.
They would write underneath on the comments:
“Why aren't you talking about the funny
women?”
Just because I didn’t!
I didn't make a blanket statement!
So political correctness is wrong, is super
ignorant—super ignorant—and super partisan.
Let me tell you something: I'm not a centrist.
I'm not right.
I consider myself a liberal, but not a lefty
if that makes sense.
I'm liberal-minded in that I'll vote for anyone
who is a good human being, whether they're
from the Green Party, Democratic Party, Republican
Party.
For me it's about humanity.
And partisanship?
I’ve got to tell you, I read everything
on the Internet and just as many liberals
are as annoying as right-wing people.
They're all annoying, everyone with this,
“Be like me or you're wrong.”
People used to make a decision; they'd see
something and they'd decide if it was true
or not.
Now they base truths on their own truth.
“I see what I believe as opposed to I'm
trying to believe what I see.”
But even the term of fake news—fuck that.
Fuck fake news.
Fuck all these terms because they're only
terms that are used by the douche bags.
They're not terms—I'm not saying you're
a douche bag for saying it, it was a question—but
the point being is: do you think I live my
day reading all sorts of material from the
Washington Post to the National Review if
I'm interested, whatever it is, do you think
that any of it I look at and go, "Well that's
fake news, fake news.
What about fake news?"
I think these are just words that are thrown
at us, they're words that are currently in
the lexicon.
They'll be gone.
It all changes, man.
It does.